y américa latina y el caribe tienen la
mayor cantidad de recursos de agua
fresca per cápita del mundo sin embargo
una tercera parte de su población no
tiene acceso a agua potable es algo que
preocupa más con fenómenos como el
cambio climático acentuando su efecto
sobre estos ecosistemas ante ese
panorama la administración del agua se
convierte en algo crucial dos ciudades
de esta zona al sur de colombia pasó y
tangua serán desde ahora el epicentro de
un proyecto de la unión europea
destinado a mejorar la gobernanza del
agua el plan se puso en marcha de la
mano de euro clima plus el programa
insignia del bloque comunitario sobre
sostenibilidad y cambio climático en
américa latina'
el objetivo es beneficiar a más de 500
mil personas con una inversión de 14
millones de euros es una gran alianza
además de las siete entidades de
carácter local regional y nacional es
una gran alianza con estas entidades
internacionales la unión europea la
agencia de desarrollo francesa de
desarrollo porque nos hacen una
subvención de unos recursos unos
recursos importantes con los cuales
vamos a poder ejecutar las diferentes
actividades
planteadas en los cuatro objetivos que
hoy expusimos algunas de esas metas son
conservar los ecosistemas y las cuencas
que abastecen los acueductos de la
región para disminuir los riesgos que
pueden causar las variaciones de las
lluvias es el único proyecto de colombia
que hace parte de ese plan de la unión
europea sin estos procesos trabajamos de
la mano con colombia colombia es un
socio estratégico un aliado en este
camino que nos hemos trazado para
cumplir con los compromisos del acuerdo
de parís
el reto es administrar un recurso que ya
cotiza en la bolsa de nueva york- esto
con los acuerdos de pares cumpliendo
cinco años y bajo la necesidad global de
reforzar sus compromisos si se quiere
llegar a la meta de cero emisiones
contaminantes para 2050